first let's start with the next chapter
in the frozen story
Olaf's frozen adventure is there's a
21-minute featurette that's going to be
released in theaters this November with
Pixar's Coco it's directed by the Emmy
winning team of Kevin deters who's
Stevie wormus from prep and landing and
produced by Oscar winner Roy Connolly
from big hero 6
it has count of four brand new songs
from the talented songwriting team of
Alicia Sam Sol and Kate Anderson and the
yeah and the entire original cast is
back ladies and gentlemen please welcome
to the stage the voice of Anna
[Applause]
so Olaf's frozen adventure takes place
during the first winter since Anna and
Elsa have reopened the doors of the
castle it's a magical time in arendelle
as the sisters Kristoff Sven and Olaf
prepare for their first holiday together
so on and Elsa welcome everyone to the
castle to celebrate the Christmas
holiday but the villagers all leave
early explaining that they have to head
home to enjoy their own family
traditions and the girls are a little
disheartened they realize because they
were separated for so long they don't
actually have any holiday traditions of
their own and it breaks off - OH
breaks Olaf's tiny little icy heart to
see the girls so sad so he decides to
take it upon himself to cheer them up
he tells Sven let's go find the best
traditions on it and Elsa have ever seen
and bring them back to the castle
Olaf and Sven go door to door asking the
villagers how they celebrate the
holidays and as Olaf collects these
traditions he starts feeling a bit
musical ladies and gentlemen please
welcome Josh - hey I just I just
happened to be in the neighborhood I
just happened to be in the neighborhood
writing the artist formerly known as
Tower of Terror and I thought it would
drop in hey Kristen hey guy need a
little help with your presentation yeah
okay let's do this live mm-hmm
happy merry holly jolly season's
greetings here I'm wondering what your
family does at that time of year love
and joy and peace on earth and tidings
of good cheer you have tradition things
for that time of year yeah
No
[Applause]
you